[Music]
what's up guys i
am super excited to be opening up this
package
this is my new camera so my birthday
just passed not too long ago and tiff
decided to buy me
a new cinema camera for the past five
years of running this vlog channel i've
kind of just discarded all my
fancier cameras i've been using a lot of
point-and-shoot cameras like this one
and i've been missing playing with
lenses and just you know doing things a
little more like how i used to do it for
just kidding films so tiff decided to
buy me a brand new camera for my
birthday
it was back ordered this camera this is
a the new sony
fx3 super really popular in high demand
and
it was back ordered until now so it's
finally come in
i'm going to open it
sweet this is okay so the cool thing
about this camera this is a
cinema line camera and it is a
full-frame camera so
for those of you guys that don't know
what that means a lot of dslr cameras
are crop frame they don't have a big
enough sensor to give you the full frame
and all the cameras ever had are all
crop frame and so this is my first
personally owned full-frame camera i
think that's what makes this
the most exciting after all these years
of being in video
i never really got myself a camera
look at this guy oh i like it alright so
another cool thing about this camera is
the fact that it comes with this
xlr audio input handle
so you can hold it like this and this
part goes on top of the shoe here and
you can carry the camera like this like
an emg
camera so that's pretty cool so it's
kind of like a hybrid body of
a dslr with eng style
like capabilities so no need to buy a
cage for it to
have extra screws and this also comes
with a lot of screws here too
so you can do a lot of the stuff just
built into this camera already
all right this is what we're looking at
does it come charged
can i play with it now oh another
birthday present this came in
actually on my birthday but this is a 35
millimeter
cinema lens uh by slr magic i wanted a
really dumb lens and but when i say dumb
lens
and elenza doesn't offer auto focusing
or
auto this is completely manual i've gone
so far into the point-and-shoot realm
for the past couple years that
i'm just really missing good
old-fashioned
video making so
let's assemble this camera shall we
take this out
[Music]
[Music]
oh my goodness record the first clip
i'm recording oh my gosh this is cool
look at how it lights up rare
whoa i'm recording
oh my goodness look at look at the bokeh
on this lens
oh i'm really happy with this lens wow
happy as can be
[Music]
baby hey guess what i'm using right now
what are you using
i don't know what are you using just
kidding i know you're using your
birthday present
yeah you like it yes i love it this is
uh
my favorite gift you've ever given me
honestly
i like to see you happy thanks baby have
you gotten the hang of it yet
nope i'm still learning how to use it
like i was telling everyone in the video
i got a very uh quote-unquote dumb lens
meaning there's no autofocus on this
thing like super manual
why i'm a man of manual things i like
manual cars and i
now i guess i like manual cameras too
yeah it's pretty hard though well
you got wanted true you like a challenge
yes
so what are we doing today we're hiking
on the trail enjoying nature
i'm trying to get a shot
oh yeah go check it out
[Music]
oh it's a bungee
my jacket what are you doing
i'm nervous for you right now married an
adventure adventurous woman
i think i'm gonna work on this oh my god
it looks like you're about to get
catapulted off
[Laughter]
you have good reaction skills though you
hang on you hung on
because you've seen well you've seen
fail videos of people like letting go of
the rope and they're just kind of
completely oh
[Music]
the shot's so nice but then you're like
all struggling what are you doing into
superman
[Music]
oh
[Music]
there we go nice
[Music]
hey you got the hang of it
[Music]
so
[Music]
hmm
[Music]